[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
is time for another myth chases episode
this week we are looking at flying boats
mechs walking on water and of course
there is another challenge for you guys
to get in a video so if you have any
myths you'd like to test throw them in
the comments below and let's do this
[Music]
let's start with those potential flying
boats our first myth is from Bismarck
e77 who says boats fly by using the cube
vent things at steamy stacks good myth
let's get a boat and let's try this do
you think the Bob will fly or sail
across the water well there's actually
more going on here than first meets the
eye
upon closer inspection the folks seems
to be glued to the ground or the GU
stuff underneath but if we jump out of
the boat and fly around a little then
get back in the boat the lift effect is
applied to the vehicle and the boat
begins to fly I can't steer it to save
my life can you how far can you get a
boat to fly over the island anyone
thinking maybe flying boats sky based
challenge maybe moving on here's a great
myth from always me who says get a
zombie to steamy stacks and they will
fly in the power plant that sounds epic
so we've got to try this
I got a rally in the morning to do this
one and luckily there were people from
Australia in our discard who helped me
out so thank you very much
we all had roles I was in charge of
bridges and the other guys were looking
for heels and mats we would definitely
go into the storm on this one because
Harry the husk takes so long to me under
all the way to steamy stacks it was
painfully slow but we got there and then
we found another problem
Harry refused to go into the draft zone
things were getting tense but suddenly
he decided to walk on our tile and once
it was broken will he fly or will he die
in the liquid below are you ready for
this epic gamer moment
[Music]
well it's actually neither option he
just stands on the Kevin juice and Minds
his own business all this hard work for
absolutely nothing and worse still he
out survived all of us in the storm
damn it here's a question from novel
painter 392 who asks can you rock it and
get on a zip line so I believe he's
asking if we can rock your ride and get
on to that zip line that sounds pretty
good to me and here it is and Wow yeah
it's possible and it works like a charm
but that's not the end of his myth novel
painter 392 also asks if we can jump off
as if light and land on a rocket I had a
go I failed miserably so he puts out a
call on our discard for someone epic
enough to jump from the zipline onto a
rocket many answered the call but no one
could do it but then up step this chap
spear spotter and this happened
[Music]
Jiji my friend excellent work but now I
put it to you can you do both in one
action can you rock it right connect to
a zip line and then jump from that zip
line on to another rockets I challenge
you if you do this please upload to
YouTube and I will use the clip in next
week's episode also on our discard I
have a new rank for people who helped me
out and do these impossible challenges
you shall be our hero of the week next
myth this next one is more of a question
from eternal burst who asks what happens
when you happen someone on a zipline
let's test this who's expecting them to
be dragged to their death well check
this as expected the weapons are
seventy-five damaged but surprisingly
the zipline is far stronger than the
harpoon gun they do not get pulled
towards you they stay on the zipline and
then we did this the other way round and
if you were on the zipline everything
works as expected you drag the person
over and if they're quick enough they
can attach themselves to the zipline or
they can fall to their death if they do
attach then you must have a harpoon face
off
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
hold on that hit for 150 damage
interesting I'll look into this here's a
quick one while we're here at this part
of the map
Kizer beam says you can rock it right
inside steamy stacks hmm what do you
think will the player stay rooted to the
rocket or lifted by the updraft let's
test it
sadly myth busted you cannot rock it
right here a quick update on last week's
challenge I asked you to rocket ride
between two rockets well so many of you
managed it but I didn't know which one
to pick
and then this one turned up from Aquaman
903 71 his friends did this but they did
this back in chapter 1 and it made me
think about the old map and I adore
their reactions - so here you go
GG aqua and the team another rocket
based myth now comes from another kiwi
who says myth a rusty can can stop an
RPG okay now I feel like I'm being set
up to be murder iced but let's try this
I originally thought the rocket would
face through the camp
but look the camp does indeed hit the
rocket which gives out a small explosion
it sadly though isn't enough to blow the
rocket to pieces but it does make
contact and gives a small explosion so
another myth busted
sadly we cannot stop an RPG with a
simple can the next myth is
world-changing coming from mzx 23 lovely
name who says can you get a fortnight
girlfriend TUF TUF myth mr. M Z but I
can reveal you can indeed do this
there's a super secret tactic it's
simple enough all you've got to do in a
solos game land at retail row and clear
out the location make sure you are the
last sole survivor now simply walk up to
the giant fish and dance if done
correctly the fish will begin to dance
back with you and this will happen girls
they come a-runnin now you have a
fortnight girlfriend but which one will
you choose oh and one other thing I
really should tell you here well warn
you here girl doesn't always mean female
girl can mean guy in real life but
beggars can't be choosers alright enjoy
the secret my friend ok back to more
important things
here's an interesting one from Darth yo
sheis who asks can partner emotes like
the high-five save you from fall damage
this one's got a lot of potential let's
try it will set up a non fatal erection
and jumped off with a player below
already with the amount would we still
take fall damage if the emote is
triggered at the same time as hitting
the ground
the idea was good but suddenly not fall
damage cannot be prevented with a
two-player emote we tried both remotes
that we had at this time of making the
video but sadly no great question death
but this myth is busted the next myth
has nothing to do with game mechanics
but it's a trolls wet dream Alex B says
myth you can land a bottle flip on a
knocked player well Alex you want us to
throw junk at a downed player I'm
definitely up for this let's give this a
try so I got the PSG discarding bolt and
there was quite delighted to take part
in throwing things at me but sadly the
bottles passed through the person
knocked and bounced away at strange
angles so unfortunately this troll meme
will never see the light of day the next
myth is from someone I forgot to write
the name off so I apologize but if this
is yours thank you very much
they say can you eliminate 10 players
with a single trap trigger hmm how many
people do you think is possible to
murder eyes in one attempt so let's try
it this is the trap O Matic it's a
simple construction but does a great job
we dropped a different number of people
in the trap and there was a few
occasions where random numbers were
eliminated but in 9 out of 10 times
the trap killed 8 people exactly so myth
busted you cannot kill 10 people with a
single trap trigger what's even more
interesting here is that the eight
people eliminated are completely random
you have as much chance of surviving
next to the spikes as opposed to being
anywhere else in the blast radius
check out these guys literally touching
the side of the spikes and they remain
unhurt I don't know if this information
is useable but it's definitely
interesting isn't it so I thought I'd
share maybe there is a certain point in
this blast radius where you can be
protected we'll look into it another
time and a quick note while we were
doing this in a public lobby someone
went out of their way to build hot watch
oh it's so beautiful I miss you at watch
thank you that person and then of course
someone came and destroyed it straight
away
yay all right back to the video and
finally lots of people have asked about
the mechs coming back or other vehicles
so instead of answering those myths
specifically right now for example can
you high-five a brute I thought I'd show
you how each vehicle behaves at the
moment on the real island for example
the groups don't sink in water and can
straight up in a route or run across a
lake the one vehicle which looks ready
to return instantly though is the Super
Monkey Ball aka the bowler it floats in
water and as you'd expect you can't be
submerged drastically so if I had a
guest to say which vehicle was coming
back sooner than later
I'd say it's these spherical boogers
right here but what about the other
vehicles you may ask well every other
vehicle sinks in water from the ATK to
the quad to the hoverboard even the
plane this is a bad thing until you
realize it's impossible to drown went
inside a vehicle so yeah at present
these won't be coming back anytime soon
unless a random update appears and this
season those are possible they really
are I miss patch notes and map updates
oh well onwards and upwards right there
we go I think that's enough myths for
one day thank you very much for watching
and of course a huge thank you to anyone
who has used my code in the war night
shop I say it every week but I really
mean it you guys are legends stay that
way I love you for it
thank you kindly I'm Adam from
Playstation grenades been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]